А зараз - «heute journal» з
Гайнцом Вольфом і Марієттою Сломкою.
Доброго вечора.
Це відбулося, так би мовити, паралельно.
Сьогодні парламент Німеччини лібералізував
право на аборти,
так що відтепер лікарські практики та
клініки зможуть рекламувати свої послуги
щодо проведення абортів.
Практично в той же час Верховний суд США вирішує
скасувати ліберальне право на аборти,
яке дотепер діяло в усій країні.
Віднині американські штати,
зважаючи на політичну ситуацію,
можуть навіть повністю заборонити аборти.
Таке повернення в минуле зумовлене
особливостями політичної системи США,
адже суддів, які приймали це рішення,
призначив ще колишній президент Дональд Трамп.
З Вашингтону - Анна Файст.
Ранок п'ятниці, 10:10, місто Вашингтон.
Крики радості, душ із шампанського.
Провокаційна зловтіха.
Ви програли! Ви програли!
Програли!
На думку протилежної сторони, програла саме демократія.
Верховний суд у Вашингтоні скасував ліберальне право на аборти,
яке діяло в США протягом 50 років.
На думку певної групи людей,
це удар по свободі та праві на самовизначення.
Ви чортові лицеміри!
Вдаєте, ніби мова йде про дітей,
але це не так!
На думку протестуючих, лицеміри - це Верховний суд США,
у якому з часів президентства Трампа переважають консерватори.
Ось як вони пояснюють скасування права на аборти:
Конституція не надає права на аборти.
Повноваження щодо регулювання
проведення абортів
повертається до народу та обраних народних представників.
Так, у 13 штатах відтепер діють закони,
які забороняють або значно обмежують проведення абортів.
У деяких штатах винятками не є навіть вагітність
через зґвалтування чи інцест.
У решті 13 штатах поки немає нових положень,
проте також плануються заборони або ж суворі обмеження.
Водночас такі штати, як Нью-Йорк та Каліфорнія,
закріпили право на аборти у своєму законодавстві.
У обґрунтуванні суду -
також і рекомендація щодо перегляду положень
про засоби контрацепції, одностатеві стосунки і одностатеві шлюби.
На думку демократів, це суперечить принципам правової держави.
Це рішення є результатом свідомих намагань
порушити рівновагу нашої правової системи,
які здійснювалися протягом десятиліть.
Це втілення екстремістської ідеології.
Це є трагічною помилкою Верховного суду.
Але без достатньої більшості демократи
навряд чи зможуть щось вдіяти.
Тому поки це тріумф людини,
яка вважає це все своєю заслугою.
«Це стало можливим лише тому, що я
зробив усе так, як обіцяв.
Зокрема йдеться про призначення на посаду
трьох високоповажних та компетентних конституційних суддів
Верховного суду США.
Для мене це було честю.
Тим часом продовжується протест тих,
хто не хоче миритися з новим положенням щодо абортів.
Деякі представники лівих уже погрожують «ніччю гніву».
Президент Байден застерігає, що насилля нічого не вирішить.
Розкол суспільства здається все більшим і більшим.
Бен'ямін Даніель з Вашингтону.
Чи дійсно таке рішення матиме політичні наслідки?
Так, справді.
Завжди варто бути обережним зі словами на кшталт «історичний»,
коли йдеться про такі рішення.
Але в цьому випадку дійсно можна говорити про історичне рішення,
яке, за словами Джо Байдена,
відкидає країну на 150 років назад.
Декілька годин тому Джо Байден висловився стосовно цього,
назвавши це неправильним рішенням і
сумним днем для Верховного суду США і для всієї країни.
Адже тут консерваторська меншість здобула перевагу
над більшістю американського народу.
Це неодмінно призведе до загострення ситуації
й ця тема ще довго буде непокоїти американців,
зокрема й у контексті проміжних виборів у листопаді.
Саме Дональд Трамп усе це почав, чи не так?
Так.
Ми дійсно можемо так сказати.
За час свого президентства він призначив на посаду у Верховний суд
3-х нових суддів, з яких усі є ультраконсерваторами.
І вже тоді йому було зрозуміло,
що таким чином він радикально змінить законодавство США
на довгі роки.
Отже, ці зміни буде відчутно ще довго після його каденції.
Його стратегія та стратегія Республіканської партії загалом,
здається, працює.
Вона спрямована не лише на найвищі органи влади, як-от Верховний суд.
Радикалізація відбувається на всіх рівнях.
Це спосіб знайти все більше приводів для боротьби культур,
щоб скористатися цим під час передвиборчої кампанії.
Наслідком є те, що суспільство не згуртовується,
чого хочуть мільйони американців,
а все більше й більше розколюється.
Дякую, Бен'яміне.
Застосування на війні голоду як зброї
не є чимось новим.
Оточити противника й заморити його голодом
або ж підпалити поля чи заблокувати торговельні шляхи -
усі ці методи існують ще віддавна.
Проте метод Путіна
в його загарбницькій війні
має новий, глобальний вимір: через те, що Україна,
яка є важливим постачальником пшениці,
зараз практично не може її експортувати,
і Росія також не експортує
в таких кількостях, як раніше,
іншим регіонам світу, особливо Африці, загрожує голод.
Це не небажаний побічний ефект, це система.
Сьогодні на Всесвітній продовольчій конференції в Берліні
було обговорено стратегії запобігання голоду.
Далі - Андреас Кюнаст.
Російські бомби падають на українські поля,
руйнують українські порти
та зерносховища.
Російські бомби руйнують світовий порядок.
До війни Україна експортувала
5 млн тонн зерна щомісяця.
У 1-й місяць війни їй вдалося експортувати лише 200 тис. тонн,
а ще понад 2 млн тонн транспортувати було просто неможливо.
Російська армія спустошує українські ферми та зерносховища,
вона краде українське зерно та обладнання для його збору.
Вона блокує українські порти.
Його б вистачило багатьом:
25 млн тонн зерна застрягло на українських кораблях
у портах Чорного моря,
тоді як 900 млн людей не вистачає їжі,
тоді як політики з усього світу намагаються
все ж запобігти найстрашнішій продовольчій кризі
з часів Другої світової війни.
Сьогодні вдень у Берліні представники 40 держав
шукали вихід із ситуації - транспортні шляхи,
шляхи виживання для цілих сімей,
цілих сіл, для цілого покоління.
Перед самітом G7 Німеччина має намір
закликати до дій якомога більше політиків.
І це все лише через одного,
який не дотримується своїх обіцянок.
Президент Путін ще декілька тижнів тому пообіцяв
розблокувати шляхи експорту зерна з України, передусім морські.
Але така обіцянка нічого не варта,
якщо її не було дотримано.
Цього тижня президент Путін сидів поряд,
коли його головна пропагандистка розповідала щось,
що сама назвала жартом.
Ось він: «ми покладаємо всі надії на голод.
Щойно почнеться голод, з нас буде знято санкції
і всі захочуть бути нашими друзями,
адже розуміють, що не бути нашими друзями - неможливо».
Тоді в Санкт-Петербурзі ніхто не засміявся вголос.
Путін показує своє задоволення також тихо.
У багатьох країнах вірять його твердженням про те,
що в голоді винні не Росія та розв'язана нею війна,
а Захід та його санкції.
Все більше відвертої брехні,
за допомогою якої Москва намагається
поміняти місцями злочинця та жертву.
Цьому ми протиставляємо нашу єдність,
помітну також і на цій конференції.
Перед тим, як перший корабель із зерном вирушить у дорогу,
Україна мусить прибрати всі міни,
які вона встановила задля захисту Одеського порту.
Для цього їй необхідні гарантії від Росії щодо ненападу.
Зерна мало, а довіри до Росії ще менше.
Про ці проблеми ми поговоримо
з міністром сільського господарства Німеччини
Джемом Оздеміром.
Доброго вечора, пане Оздеміре.
Доброго вечора, пані Сломка.
Чи вірите Ви, що все ж вийде
вивезти кораблі з зерном з Одеського порту?
Чи, можливо, варто облишити цю ідею
й зосередитися на інших шляхах експорту?
В будь-якому разі в Україні
ніхто не вірить Володимиру Путіну.
І я добре розумію, чому.
Адже навіть якщо, як це вже не раз бувало,
настане режим тиші,
то Володимир Путін - це все ж Володимир Путін.
Він може в будь-який момент
знову заблокувати Україну.
Він може знову шантажувати її.
Тому варто налаштуватися на те, що шляхи експорту,
альтернативні до морського, мають бути не тимчасовими, а постійними.
Інша проблема полягає в тому, що українці замінували порт,
щоб захиститися.
Тоді їм доведеться розмінувати порти
та повірити росіянам, що вони цим
не скористаються.
Я трохи здивована, що Генсек ООН
має досить оптимістичні погляди щодо цього.
Україна бере участь у цих переговорах.
Але ніхто не може справді довіряти Володимиру Путіну
після всіх обіцянок, яких він не дотримався.
Ми також не можемо радити Україні
погоджуватися на це.
Тому зараз це є нашим завданням
як світової спільноти,
як Європейського Союзу, як Німеччини,
разом з сусідніми країнами та країнами,
що межують з Україною,
знайти найкращі альтернативні маршрути
для транспортування зерна з України
на постійній основі.
У сьогоднішній розмові
із моїм українським колегою Миколою Сольським,
було ясно, що Україна хотіла б мати
альтернативний маршрут на постійній основі.
Вона також готова взяти на себе зобов'язання
щодо обсягів перевезень,
тому знову постає
питання економічної доцільності.
Це, ймовірно, більш довгостроковий захід,
тому що є багато проблем:
залізничні лінії, ширина колії яких
відрізняється від ширини колії у країнах ЄС тощо.
Тож наразі, цього зернового сезону,
зерно, ймовірно, доведеться постачати звідкись ще,
щоб не було загрози більшого голоду в Африці.
Але звідки?
З альтернативними маршрутами все не так погано.
Якщо до війни середній обсяг перевезень
через Чорне море
становив 5 млн тонн,
то у травні ми отримали 1,7 млн тонн.
Останні дані, які я отримав сьогодні
від мого українського колеги,
свідчать, що вони можуть збільшити цей показник
ще десь до 2 млн тонн.
Це досить багато.
Але є дві проблеми: з погляду логістики ми
вийшли за рамки.
Також те, що Ви згадали - наявність вагонів -
також є проблемою в Європі.
На будівництво нових підуть роки.
Наявність вантажівок - теж серйозна проблема.
І ми маємо ще одну проблему:
вартість завантаження кораблів
у Румунії зростає.
Ціна, яку, до речі, доводиться платити
й румунським фермерам,
яким це не дуже подобається.
В Україні падають ціни на зерно,
тобто вирощування зерна не окупається
для багатьох українських фермерів.
Нині вони розглядають можливість
вирощування інших продуктів.
Тому Україні потрібна перспектива, інший шлях.
Поки що ми допомагаємо вивезти якнайбільше зерна.
Але в довгостроковій перспективі потрібен маршрут,
альтернативний до морського.
Ми також маємо шукати нові місця
для вирощування пшениці.
Чи не перебуваєте Ви зараз у схожій ситуації,
як і Ваш колега Роберт Габек,
коли, можливо, доведеться робити те,
що, як депутату від Зелених,
робити не дуже хочеться?
Він закликав збільшувати запаси вугілля,
а Вам, можливо, доведеться відмовитися
від відведення земель для підтримання ﻿біорізноманіття.
Так, я цим займаюся.
Я зробив відповідну пропозицію Єврокомісії
щодо Спільної аграрної політики,
що почне діяти 2023 року.
Чи можна вирощувати пшеницю на тому самому полі
два роки поспіль -
це питання сівозміни,
яка з погляду екології є необхідною,
щоб ґрунт міг відпочити.
Однак я вніс пропозицію, щоб ми, як виняток,
вирощували пшеницю на тому самому полі,
щоб збільшити обсяги пшениці
в короткостроковій перспективі.
Втім, я вважаю неправильним,
як радять зараз деякі з ЄС,
повторювати помилки минулого
та відкладати боротьбу з втратою біорізноманіття
та кліматичною кризою.
Тому я зауважив, що варто працювати над збереженням
біорізноманіття ґрунтів.
Я виділив ці землі під вирощування кормових культур,
але не повністю.
Тому моя порада - зважувати кожне рішення,
розглядати кожну деталь,
а потім намагатися знайти рішення.
Але не треба забувати,
що однією з причин голоду в світі
є кліматична криза.
Заходи, що лише посилюють кліматичну кризу,
не можуть бути доцільними.
В довгостроковій перспективі - не можуть,
але зараз людям потрібно щось їсти,
щоб вони не померли від голоду
протягом наступних місяців.
Чи не повинні ми тоді відкинути зараз інші міркування
та вирощувати культури, використовувати поля
у такий спосіб, який з екологічного погляду
не є правильним?
Це дійсно так.
Але давайте тоді поговоримо про землю,
про відведення земель під будівництво,
що в Німеччині безперешкодно продовжується,
та й навіть розширюється.
Давай поговоримо про будівництво автомагістралей.
У нас одна з найщільніших дорожніх мереж
у всьому світі,
а ми, як чемпіони світу, будуємо ще.
Ми втрачаємо цінні землі.
Давайте поговоримо про те, чи це дійсно має сенс.
Вже давно винайшли електромобільність -
альтернативу двигуну внутрішнього згоряння.
Чому ми вирощуємо енергетичні культури на землях,
які можна використати для вирощування
харчових продуктів?
Якщо моя модель реформування тваринництва,
яку я зараз просуваю, буде успішною,
то отримаємо землі, що використовуватимемо
для вирощування кормових культур,
а потім і для харчових продуктів.
Є багато можливостей.
Цікаво, що деяким колегам завжди спадає на думку те,
що особливо шкодить природі.
А те, що покращує ситуацію із землями,
їх не цікавить.
Я знаю їхні наміри і звідки вітер віє.
Це був міністр сільського господарства Німеччини Джем Оздемір.
Дякую. До побачення.
На сайті zdf.heute ви можете знайти
безліч відеоматеріалів та довідкової інформації
про Путінську війну
та її світові наслідки.
На початку програми я вже зазначила,
що парламент Німеччини сьогодні
змінив правову ситуацію щодо абортів.
Детальніше про це розповість Гайнц Вольф.
Йдеться про заборону реклами абортів.
Раніше спірний параграф 219а
Кримінального кодексу Німеччини
регулював цю заборону.
Його анулюють.
Сьогодні в парламенті Німеччини за це проголосувала
переважна більшість.
Фракції партій CDU/CSU та AfD проголосували проти.
Рішення парламенту також передбачає,
що вироки, винесені з 1990 року за параграфом 219a,
будуть скасовані.
Уряд Німеччини скасовує так звані «тести для громадян»,
тобто безплатні експрес-тести на COVID-19
без відповідних підстав.
З наступного четверга за тест
потрібно буде платити 3 євро.
За певних причин, як-от відвідування лікарні
або будинку для людей похилого віку,
тест буде безкоштовним.
Це рішення оголосив міністр охорони здоров'я
Карл Лаутербах
після погодження з міністром фінансів
Крістіаном Лінднером.
Партія Лівих розпочала федеральний партійний з'їзд
у місті Ерфурт.
На початку очільниця Джанін Вісслер
закликала свою партію згуртуватися та репрезентувати
єдиний фронт перед зовнішнім світом.
Останнім часом партія Лівих оговтувалася
від поганих результатів виборів
та звинувачень в сексизмі.
Завтра мають відбутися вибори
партійного керівництва.
Кількість загиблих внаслідок руйнівного землетрусу
в Афганістані в середу
зросла щонайменше до 1100.
Хоча перші партії гуманітарної допомоги від ООН
прибули на схід країни сьогодні вранці,
жителі багатьох зруйнованих сіл
досі чекають на допомогу.
Кілька афтершоків та сильний дощ
ускладнюють проведення рятувальних робіт.
Як повідомляють, під уламками
тисяч зруйнованих будинків
можуть перебувати ще багато тіл загиблих.
Завершився саміт ЄС у Брюсселі.
Темами останнього дня були
високі ціни на енергоносії та дефіцит газу.
Канцлер Олаф Шольц заявив, що було вжито всіх заходів
для налагодження імпорту енергії
з інших країн, крім Росії.
За його словами, ці зусилля мають посилюватися.
Якщо поглянути на перебіг війни в Україні,
то загальна картина не є однозначною.
Подекуди українці наважуються на нові наступи,
можливо, завдяки новим системам озброєння,
які ﻿нещодавно надав Захід.
Однак на Донеччині українська армія
не залишатиметься на колишніх позиціях у боротьбі
за окуповане місто Сєвєродонецьк.
Після кількох тижнів бойових дій,
кровопролитних та з великими втратами,
українські війська відходять.
На півдні, на Херсонщині, тривають бойові дії.
Херсон окупований російськими військами,
і Україна сподівається звільнити його,
якщо матиме відповідну зброю.
Наша репортерка Катрін Айґендорф зараз на фронті.
Ми в селі Широке, на лінії фронту на Херсонщині.
Російська армія - всього за кілька кілометрів звідси.
Андрій показує мені позицію,
яку вони займають тут уже 3 місяці:
на невеликій ділянці лісу між полями.
У них ледве вистачає набоїв для автоматів Калашнікова,
а для обстрілу віддалених російських позицій
вони мають лише
стару артилерійську у﻿становку 1985 року.
Ситуація стає дедалі критичнішою,
противник стягує дедалі більше техніки та військових,
але поки що ми тримаємося досить непогано.
Все буде добре.
Андрій показує нам відео їхнього останнього
вистрілу з установки.
Це свідчить, наскільки безнадійною є боротьба
з такою зброєю.
Ситуація повністю змінюється,
коли використовується нова зброя.
Тоді весь характер війни тут одразу змінюється.
Окопи - як зі старого військового фільму.
Імпровізований табір:
на кухні просто неба вони зберігають їжу,
частину якої принесли самі.
Андрій показує мені, де вони ховаються,
коли російська армія обстрілює їхні позиції.
Укриття, де вони також можуть переночувати.
Після кількох тижнів очікування
із Заходу надійшла перша сучасна зброя.
Олександр розкладає на полі протитанкові гармати
США та Великобританії,
показує, як вони працюють.
Високоточна зброя, яка, на думку військових,
може змінити перебіг війни.
Хоча у російської сторони
набагато більше військової техніки,
така зброя з Заходу дозволяє їм здійснювати контратаки
з більшою ймовірністю вразити ціль.
У противника проблеми з точністю,
вони все рівняють із землею,
що ми зараз спостерігаємо у таких областях,
як Луганська та Донецька,
де зараз точаться найважчі бої.
Російські військові знищують усіх:
мирні жителі чи військові - їм все одно.
На зворотному шляху нам вдалося побачити,
як сильно війна вплинула
на буденне життя у навколишніх селах.
11-річний Андрій зі своїм другом Богданом
та їхньою подругою Діаною
створили власний блокпост,
щоб перевіряти автомобілі.
Ми 17-та танкова бригада.
У нашій школі є 17-та танкова бригада - ми з неї.
Пластиковою зброєю
діти намагаються захистити свою Батьківщину,
бо для них це не просто гра.
Так звані «літні канікули» у період війни.
Про стан економіки у Німеччині, яка, звісно, також
відчуває наслідки війни,
розповість Гайнц Вольф.
Згідно з індексом ділового клімату за червень
від Інституту економічних досліджень Мюнхену ifo
стан економіки погіршився.
Тому прогнози компаній
ще песимістичніші, ніж раніше.
Франку Бетмане, як Ви можете це прокоментувати?
Малоперспективно.
Якщо вірити прогнозами топ-менеджменту,
багато хто говорить
про економічні труднощі
у другій половині року.
Рівень стурбованості зростає.
Проте опитування щодо прогнозів проводилося
перед тим, як оголосили «режим тривоги», тобто
другий рівень аварійного плану щодо газу,
що, очевидно, зробить прогнози ще невтішнішими.
Економіка намагається вистояти,
але зіштовхується з цілою низкою труднощів:
не лише рекордний рівень інфляції,
але й різке зростання цін на сировину та енергоносії,
а також очікуване зростання
ключових відсоткових ставок,
які в майбутньому призведуть
до здорожчання інвестицій.
Через сильну залежність від газу
особливо вразливою є хімічна промисловість.
Експерт з економіки Інституту ifo Клаус Вольраб
підтверджує похмурі настрої і в роздрібній торгівлі.
Однак погіршення індексу ділового клімату
не відлякує інвесторів.
До кінця тижня фондовий індекс Німеччини DAX може зрости
аж на 200 пунктів або 1,6%.
Деякі експерти кажуть, що це дуже тимчасове зростання.
Інші ж, навпаки, зазначають,
що 40 компаній зі списку DAX,
за первинними оцінками, будуть заробляти так багато
як ніколи раніше,
незважаючи на цьогорічні негативні прогнози.
Франку Бетмане, дуже дякую!
Cьогодні ввечері у Берліні відбулося
вручення Німецької кінопремії.
Драма «Lieber Thomas» здобула загалом 9 нагород,
у тому числі нагороду «Золота Лола»
за найкращий художній фільм.
Жіноча збірна Німеччини з футболу виграла
останній товариський матч перед
чемпіонатом Європи, який почнеться у липні.
У матчі проти Швейцарії, який німкені виграли з рахунком 7:0,
перед 6 тис. публікою особливо відзначилася Клара Бюль,
якій вдалося забити аж 3 голи.
Після «генеральної репетиції» на полі
німецька команда їде на чемпіонат Європи в Англію.
Уже другий день в Берліні проходять змагання Finals:
чемпіонат Німеччини у 14 видах спорту.
Один із титулів сьогодні
перед Бранденбурзькими воротами
здобув колишній чемпіон світу
зі штовхання ядра Давід Шторл.
Свій десятий чемпіонський титул у Німеччині
Шторл отримав з найкращим
результатом сезону - відстань 20,32 м.
Однак це явно нижчий показник стандартів,
що встановлені на липневому
чемпіонаті світу в США.
Сімон Байєр на другому місці,
випереджаючи чемпіона Денніса Лукаса,
жоден з них не перетнув дистанцію у 20 м.
Чинний чемпіон Лукас Даузер переміг
у фіналі всіх гімнастів,
випередивши Філіпа Гердера і Гленна Требінга.
Незважаючи на слабкий старт Лукасу Даузеру,
срібному призеру Олімпійських ігор на брусах,
завдяки своїй наполегливості та продуктивності
вдається показати високі результати.
160-метровий спринт на байдарках по річці Шпреє
виграли Юла Гааке та Якоб Шопф.
У фіналі берлінець Шопф, який виграв
срібло Олімпійських ігор у Токіо,
зі своєю партнеркою з міста Люнен граційно обходять
тандем Пауліни Пашек і Макса Лемке.
Спортивна гімнастка Дар'я Варфоломеєва
вперше здобула титул
чемпіона Німеччини в багатоборстві.
15-річна дівчина обійшла чемпіонку
Маргариту Колосову
і на цих вихідних завоювала в Ізраїлі
вперше після 42 років медалі для Німеччини.
Яким був Берлін у 1920-х років? Міфічним.
У той час столиця Німеччини
вважалася ліберальною і прогресивною.
Хоча часто той час характеризують висловом
«танці на вулкані»,
адже цей післявоєнний період був також і довоєнним.
Проте не так часто згадується,
наскільки жорстокими були реалії того часу.
Скільки було замахів на життя та вбивств
тільки на початку Веймарської республіки.
Ціла серія політичних вбивств була здійснена
ультраправою терористичною організацією.
Безповоротні наслідки подій, що
трапились у цей день 100 років тому:
вбивство Вальтера Ратенау -
міністра закордонних справ
і одного з найсміливіших бійців
за молоду німецьку демократію.
Крістіан Кірш нагадує про події того дня.
На цьому місці, але в інший час: 100 років тому
застрелили Вальтера Ратенау.
У районі Берлін-Грюневальд, на вулиці Кенігсалеє
стався замах на міністра закордонних
справ Німецького Рейху.
Ратенау саме був у дорозі
до міністерства, їхав у машині.
Пістолет-кулемет та ручна граната -
шанс вижити дорівнював 0.
Міністр відмовився від охорони,
ніби не противився намірам вбивства
правих радикалів.
Маркус Мекель також був міністром закордонних справ Німеччини,
першим вільно обраним в НДР у 1990 році.
Він усвідомлює загрозу демократії,
яку несе з собою політичний екстремізм.
Ратенау, за його словами, обставав
за молоду демократію.
Для мене в 1990 році не було небезпечно.
Для Вальтера Ратенау це було фатальним,
як і для тих,
хто реально намагався заснувати демократію.
Веймарська республіка провалилася,
оскільки було занадто мало демократів.
Це вбивство було
антидемократичним вбивством з боку правих
і викликало ударну хвилю шоку по
слабкій Веймарській республіці.
Лише у Берліні сотні тисяч акцій протесту
проти вбивства єврея Ратенау,
якого ненавиділи праві радикали.
Тогочасні Ліві зневажали Ратенау -
капіталіста, сина великого промисловця.
Ратенау мав гострий розум,
був філософом, підприємцем,
інженером, художником, фізиком та дипломатом.
Журналіст Томас Гютлін
вважає Ратенау символом,
однією із центральних фігур 20-го століття,
в якому для Німеччини було так багато катастроф.
Історик Себастіан Гаффнер якось
сказав, що Гітлер і Ратенау -
два найбільш харизматичних політики
часів Веймарської республіки.
Гітлер - через свою неймовірну підлість,
Ратенау - через свою невід'ємну витонченість і інтелігентність.
Якби Ратенау не вбили, німецька історія
розвивалася б по-іншому.
Він лежав мертвий і
чекав прощальної зустрічі в Рейхстазі
- а Веймарська республіка лишилася на роздоріжжі.
Ратенау був поза часом,
далекоглядним та завбачливим.
Написане в 1913 звучить схоже на принципи ЄС:
злиття економік Європи в одну спільноту - це злиття політики,
це не гарантуватиме миру, але зекономить зусилля,
послабить конфлікти і буде цивілізацією солідарності.
Мільйони оплакували його.
Буржуазна катапульта
проти націоналістичного екстремізму.
Важливо, щоб ми не забували про жертви правих радикалів.
Навіть сьогодні, опираючись на досвід,
не можна забувати,
що ворог нашої демократії все ще існує.
Для нас важливо не забувати про цього чоловіка.
Непохитний демократ, який намагався об'єднати.
Вже 100 років він спочиває тут,
на південному сході Берліну.
На сьогодні все, з Вами був «heute journal».
О 23:45 випуск «heute journal up: date»
з Крістофером Верманом.
Якщо Ви засумували за випусками «heute show»,
у Вас буде нагода
повеселитися з фестивалем «Comedy for Future»
з Берлінського театру Шиллера.
Не нудьгуйте.
До зустрічі!
Запрошую до перегляду прогнозу погоди.
Як можна бачити на супутниковому знімку,
сьогодні вдень дихотомія погоди була справді феєричною.
На північний схід від Ельби не було жодної хмари:
сухо та спекотно.
Найвищий показник термометра у Берліні 33°,
а також у Кірхдорфі, що на Пелі -
невеликому острові у Балтійському морі.
Такі високі температури можливі у тих краях
тільки через морський вітер.
На іншій території країни
густі хмари з грозами.
Наприклад, у Гамбурзі, Ганновері,
Штутґарті та Мюнхені.
Не обійшлося без грому і блискавок.
Що ж відбувається зараз?
Над Британськими островами проходив циклон,
який перетягує з собою грози
у нічний час далі на схід.
У другій половині ночі, після опівночі,
у східній Баварії від сильного дощу
місцями можливі підтоплення, може затопити підвали.
Можливі також град і штормові вітри.
Також на півночі очікуються грози.
Загалом, сьогодні ввечері грозова активність
вже знижуватиметься від заходу.
Уночі температура коливатиметься від 10° до 18°
така ж температура
завтра вранці на річках Одер і Найсе.
Завтра знову буде по-літньому тепло,
з позначкою від 23 ° до +30° в Альтмарку.
Тепло буде також на узбережжях,
як вже сьогодні.
Ще є залишки грозового повітря на сході,
зрідка там знову йтиме сильний дощ.
На інших територіях погода покращиться:
багато сонячного проміння,
особливо на південному-заході.
З неділі на сході країни знову буде дуже спекотно.
Однак з заходу прийдуть нові грози,
які можуть викликати негоду і в понеділок.
До побачення!